pour le groupe l'est républicain la
parole est à monsieur pierre lequiller
monsieur le premier ministre
l'europe va mal comme l'a dit jean
claude juncker
schengen est dans un état comateux les
frontières intérieures dans l'union
européenne sont érigés partout
l'allemagne avec l'autriche et la
république tchèque l'autriche avec la
république tchèque la slovaquie la
hongrie et la slovénie la suède et le
danemark sur le pont de malmö et bien
sûr la france avec tous ses voisins
cette situation va sans doute se
prolonger compte tenu des circonstances
mais nous espérons que cela sera
provisoire profitons de ce délai pour
sauver l'esprit de schengen et de la
libre circulation acquis européen est
essentielle
il faut complètement le refonder
rien ne sert de vouloir le rafistoler la
refondation consiste à d'abord ériger
des règles communes en matière d'asile
et de politique de retour des migrants
illégaux
actuellement 20 % pour la france 70 %
pour l'allemagne n'adhéreront à ce
schengen 2 que les pays qui souscriront
à ses règles communes ceux qui n'en
veulent pas n'en feront pas partie en
matière de sécurité
l'état d'urgence en france que nous
avons voté ne suffit pas il y à une
urgence européenne notamment dans le
domaine du renseignement ou la
coopération est très déficiente
la france a évidemment un rôle majeur à
jouer que françois hollande n'assume pas
vous dites que l'opposition et la
majorité doivent travailler ensemble
mais cela exige aussi que vous nous
écoutez cela fait trois ans que nous
vous appelons à refonder schengen les
solutions sont connues
enfin discuter mais l'essentiel
n'est pas de discuter l'essentiel est de
faire des français quand tous les
européens attendent des actes
merci monsieur le quillier la parole et
à monsieur le ministre intérieur